I'm Greg Jarrett I'm Shannon bream I'm
Steve Ducey and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday February 1st 2023 on Attica
Rosenthal is war with China inevitable
and do we have the resources to respond
as we arm Ukraine Global tensions have
some warning and worrying about our
Readiness and if you look at the budget
for the Pentagon this year's budget
you'll see that they really are trying
to procure a range of capabilities to
deal with a range of potential threats
um you have to be as ready as possible
I'm Dave Anthony is America on a
collision course with our debt this
summer well when you deal with Congress
you anything can happen but Republicans
do not want to default and I'm David
Marcus I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
an Air Force Commander has recently said
we will likely be at war with China in
about two years time General Michael
minnahan said Xi Jinping has secured a
third term has set his war council and
taiwan's presidential elections are in
2024. the U.S he says will be distracted
then with our own election so his gut he
writes tells him we will fight the
following year the Pentagon press
secretary Patrick Ryder responded by
saying China is a pacing Challenge and
the focus is to work with allies to
preserve a peaceful and open
indo-pacific but the house Foreign
Affairs committee chairman Republican
Michael McCall told Fox News Sunday he
is worried and it could happen I think
as long as Biden is in office projecting
weakness as he did with Afghanistan that
led to Putin invading in Ukraine that
the odds are very high we could see a
conflict with China and Taiwan and the
indo-pacific the top Democrat on the
house armed services committee Adam
Smith also told Fox News Sunday between
talk of war with China and our
assistance in Ukraine he's worried about
military Readiness citing a new study
from the center for strategic and
International Studies what industry will
tell you is that the reason that they
don't have the ability to make as many
weapons as we now need is because they
don't want to make that major investment
without what they refer to as a demand
signal without knowing that we're going
to buy them U.S taxpayers don't want to
spend a ton of money or weapons that we
don't need we need to increase that
ability to Surge when we need it and
we've shown no sign of slowing down Aid
to Ukraine before Republicans took over
the house of 45 billion Aid package to
Ukraine was approved and since then
we've begun training Ukrainian soldiers
on the Patriot missile defense system
President Biden just committed to
sending more than 30 tanks to Ukraine
and when it comes to China this week a
report surfaced that the Pentagon Was
preparing for house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy to visit Taiwan in response a
Chinese foreign Ministry official said
we urge certain individuals in the U.S
to earnestly abide by the one China
policy in other words don't go we would
certainly let the commander speak for
himself I think uh the Department of
Defense is they believe and have written
it into their defense strategy but China
is their pacing challenge John Kirby's
The National Security Council
coordinator for strategic Communications
at the White House and if you look at
our national security strategy it also
lays bare quite frankly and clearly the
the threats and challenges that the PRC
posed to our own National Security
interests here at home and around the
world but it also highlights the fact
that we don't want to seek conflict with
China and there's no reason
for it this bilateral relationship of
ours to devolve into some kind of armed
conflict it is a competition a strategic
competition that President Biden
believes the United States is well
poised to come out with a strong upper
hand but there's no reason for this to
devolve into conflict and you know
secretary Lincoln will be heading over
to Beijing uh in the not too distant
future to carry out uh one of the
taskings that he got from President
Biden after President Biden's meeting
with President XI at the G20 in Bali
which is to look for ways to restore if
not Revitalize some of the bilateral
vehicles for dialogue and cooperation
that the Chinese unfortunately shut down
uh after speaker Pelosi went and visited
Taiwan one of those is military to
military dialogue military to military
Communications that now don't exist at
that level and we want to get them back
into place because miscommunication
that's where things can really you know
lead to potential tensions that never
should really arise to that level in the
first place so that's where we're going
to stay focused
the top Democrat on armed services as
you know Adam Smith he said he's
concerned given the environment right
war in Ukraine which we're supporting
with weapons and this talk now of war
with China about military Readiness and
there's been a recent study out
regarding how ready we may or may not be
and he said specifically the concern is
about our industrial base and that even
Republicans are worried alongside him
and Smith said specifically on Fox News
Sunday without a demand signal
manufacturers don't want to start making
a lot of weapons that we may not buy if
the military has to plan for a number of
possibilities how can they effectively
plan in this environment
that's actually been a bit of an eternal
task for the Pentagon to plan against
multiple scenarios every uh every so
often the military will come up with a
new National defense strategy or
National military strategy and you if
you go back and look at them
historically you'll see that in everyone
they talk about making sure the military
is poised for any number of different
contingencies some of it is Major State
on state War some of it is something a
little less than that you know in the
last 20 years so much of our Focus has
been on counter-insurgency warfare in
Iraq and Afghanistan not to mention the
threat of of cyber conflict now the
Potential Threat for space so if you
just look and if you look at the budget
for the Pentagon this year's budget
you'll see that they really are trying
to procure a range of capabilities to
deal with a range of potential threats
um you have to be as ready as possible
does that mean you're going to be ready
for every single thing that comes up
perhaps not but if you cast in that wide
and you try to invest in capabilities
and resources to better meet them you
know then you're better poised to adapt
as needed and so the Pentagon will be
doing that they will constantly be
looking at again a whole range of
threats
Democrats and Republicans have said a
lot of XI jinping's calculation
regarding Taiwan depends on how the
world responds to Ukraine I think even
President Biden has said you know he
says constantly you know at this
Crossroads between democracies and
autocracies and who will win is is our
involvement in Ukraine also part of
sending that message
it is very much about obviously
supporting Ukraine in the fight but any
autocrats any would-be adversary like
Putin you should take notice of What Not
Just the United States has done uh you
know in billions of dollars of of
support and security systems but that
the whole world has done over 143
Nations at the U.N voted to condemn
Russia's illegal annexation a few months
ago and more than 50 Nations not just
from Europe but from around the world
the Middle East and the indo-pacific
region are attending these contact
groups that secretary Austin is having
every now and then he just had one last
week in Germany coming together to
contribute security assistance weapons
capabilities even financing and funding
to the Ukrainian Armed Forces I think
any autocrat should take a long look at
how the International Community has
really rallied and come together under
President Biden's leadership to push
back on Putin's designs on Ukraine so it
is very much about Ukraine I don't want
to overstate that we are trying to make
sure that they can defend themselves
their territory their restore their
internationally recognized borders and
boundaries but yes there is clearly a
message in here for uh autocrats around
the world
President Biden said the idea that we're
going to send in offensive equipment you
know planes tanks American pilots and
Crews that he said was called World War
III he said that earlier on in the war
with Ukraine and Russia obviously we're
sending more than 30 tanks now so we've
moved on on that idea and a Ukrainian
official under President zielinski is
saying Now's the Time to make the case
for aircraft do we eventually give
aircraft as well like where how far do
we how far do we go well without getting
into future capabilities or
announcements that haven't been made
um what I can tell you is and that's
Abram's tanks it's a good example of
that we are in constant communication
with the ukrainians nearly daily about
their needs on the battlefield and the
tanks are an example of trying to stay
ahead of the needs that they're going to
have in coming months and what we
believe they're going to need in coming
months is a combined arms capability
which is why we and so many other
nations are giving them armored vehicles
which include tanks but are not just
about tanks uh because they want to be
able to maneuver an open terrain fast
quick efficiently these vehicles will
help them do that it's also about air
defense capabilities and so as the war
has evolved over time so too have the
capabilities that the ukrainians have
needed and the wool evolves uh because
Mr Putin keeps you know modifying how he
wants to brutalize the Ukrainian people
and we need to be able to evolve with it
and that's the essence of the
conversations that we're having with the
ukrainians literally every day
John just a few more for you and this is
probably an easy one I think to answer
because as you know there's a lot of
pushback now especially with Republicans
in control of the house and I see it on
social media every day this concern over
how much we spend on Ukraine I I I'm
just looking for a firm number at this
point I know there's military assistance
humanitarian assistants there have been
drawdowns there have been Congressional
spending approvals how much money
have we sent to Ukraine what is the
dollar amount on Ukraine Aid well just
in security assistance since the
beginning of the war it's about 27
billion dollars and there are certainly
billions in addition to that in terms of
financial assistance humanitarian Aid
and assistance that have been provided
it has been a substantial investment and
that's the way we look at this it's an
investment it's an investment in
Democratic principles and ideals it's an
investment in the future security of
Europe the security landscape in Europe
has drastically changed not is changing
not will change has changed the United
States now has a hundred thousand troops
on European soil that's 20 000 more than
we had before Mr Putin decided to invade
this fight over Ukraine obviously first
and foremost it's about we want to stop
this war we want to stop the killing of
innocent Ukrainian men women and
children and stop the destruction of so
many of their towns and Villages but it
is about something more it is about the
idea of sovereignty it's about the very
essence of Independence and it's not
just the United States who is donating
and contributing to this effort it
really is an international one now yes
we are leading the world in terms of
contributions that is true and we have
enjoyed tremendous bipartisan support
for those contributions there are a few
voices on Capitol Hill who are looking
at scans at this but by and large there
is tremendous bicameral and bipartisan
support for continuing these efforts in
support of Ukraine but John I'm I'm not
I'm not directly in capital here I'm
hearing from just average Everyday
People
who are saying to me and they're not
necessarily Republican but they're
they're saying you know wow 31 trillion
dollars in debt so how do you address
that concern how do you convince people
like we got to keep spending this even
though we are in massive debt
that's a great question and uh you're
right I was speaking more about the
conversations that we're having in
Washington and uh look I I get these
same questions from my own family uh my
brothers and my sister and even even my
mom you know about sort of what is this
all about and the way I put it to them
is yes it is about the founding ideal of
this country which is Independence
that's what Ukraine is fighting for and
again I think that I think everybody can
understand that but imagine how much
more this country and all other allies
and partners would have to spend perhaps
not just in Treasure but in blood if
what Mr Putin is doing to Ukraine is
successful if he gets to redraw the map
of Europe how much more emboldened will
he be where will he stop and how much
more effort and how much more time how
much more blood will have to be shed not
just by ukrainians but by others if he
is allowed to succeed in this blatant
brutal an illegal war in Ukraine
um we wanted to stop now believe me if
this war could end today I think
everybody would be happy to see that
um and it could end today quite frankly
if Mr Putin would do the right thing
that doesn't appear to to be uh in his
Playbook he wants to keep fighting and
keep killing so we've got to make sure
that Ukraine can keep succeeding on the
battlefield so that when it does come to
a close the ukrainians can be successful
at the negotiating table they can
preserve their sovereignty they can hold
on to that Independence and this war
won't escalate Beyond it won't stretch
and grow and metastasize into something
that could be much more costly not just
in terms of dollars but in terms of
human lives
John Kirby National Security Council
coordinator at the White House thank you
so much for joining us my pleasure thank
you
[Music]
this is David Marcus with your Fox News
commentary coming up
will either of them blink
I mean figuratively of course President
Biden is supposed to meet today with
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy in a
standoff over the nation's debts the
only person who's being irresponsible
that could affect the markets is the
president by being that spoiled child
said I will not talk I will not meet you
know you just have to raise the debt
limit Republicans have been demanding
spending cuts be attached to raising
that limit with McCarthy telling Fox
Business to think that the president
believes there's no place in government
you can't cut and have a savings for the
hard-working taxpayers there's so much
waste out there the president has said
he will not negotiate on Tuesday before
traveling to New York City he was asked
McCarthy show me his budget
show me his budget last month the
president said this about House
Republicans you know the fiscally
demented I think they don't they don't
quite get it all of this ahead of the
risk that the U.S could default by June
if the debt limit is not increased well
when you deal with Congress you anything
can happen but Republicans do not want
to default Congressman Jason Smith from
Missouri is Chairman of the house Ways
and Means Committee for weeks now
speaker McCarthy and House Republicans
have been calling on President Biden and
Senator Schumer to come to the table to
address this fiscal Insanity that's
going on and let's figure out where we
can get an agreement where you increase
a debt limit but you also address the
fiscal insanity if there's not any kind
of negotiation you're just postponing
the next debt crisis if you look at
history since 1985 in fact eight of the
largest fiscal restraints that's been
ever been put in order by Congress were
all tied to a debt limit increase most
recent that was a huge magnitude was
back in 2011 when Joe Biden was vice
president under Barack Obama where they
did a caps agreement over 10 years that
saved trillions of dollars so what is it
specifically that you want attached to
an increase in the debt limit you know
we have one aspect of government the
Republicans control the House of
Representatives of course the Democrats
control the Senate and Joe Biden's in
the white house
um we just need something we need
something to deliver for working-class
families farmers and small businesses
they are facing the highest Spike of
goods because of record inflation in 40
years because of Reckless government
spending and they want us to reduce that
crazy spending and get our fiscal house
in order so policies that can help move
us in that direction we're not going in
there saying we have to have one two or
three we're going in saying let's work
together all right your colleague who
used to be chair of the house ways in
the Means Committee when Democrats ran
the house Richard Neal he says that he
wants a clean vote of course and he says
of Republicans they voted for increased
defense spending some voted for the the
infrastructure bill that passed last
year some voted for the chips act that
passed last year and the support for
Ukraine and all the other things dictate
that you have to have a clean vote on
the debt ceiling so he's saying
Republicans are part of what you had
said was fiscal Insanity I would
disagree with him because we're the
fiscal Insanity happened was the two
trillion dollar reconciliation Bill
where not one Republican voted for that
is what spiked the inflation fire
inflation was 1.4 percent whenever Joe
Biden took the oath of office two months
later they passed that two trillion
dollar spending Bill and then you led to
inflation increasing 13.9 percent since
Joe Biden's taken the oath of office and
what did people get for that they got
checks to federal prisoners there was
hundreds of billions of dollars of fraud
hundreds of billions of dollars paid
people not to work when we have Labor
shortages all over the country it was
legislation that bankrupt the economy
but it benefited the wealthy their
wealthy environmentalist donors got
extreme welfare I mean there was welfare
in that proposal for wealthy
corporations and Wealthy entities it's a
shame and then the inflation reduction
act not one Republican voted for that's
another item as well so they spent
trillions of dollars of their own
mandatory spending through these
reconciliation packages that not one
Republican voted for so it's not fair
for him to say that now Democrats have
claimed the inflation reduction act will
cut the deficit I mean that's what that
was one of the arguments they said only
if you spend 745 billion dollars does
Washington Democrats believe that that
cuts the deficit and just add up the
numbers I think I think anyone with half
of a brain can figure that out
if there is zero negotiation from the
president they and he sticks by it all
the way to June not doing anything but a
clean debt limit then what
I would hope that President Joe Biden
would not want to default on our debt if
we gave him a piece of legislation that
increased the debt limit that also put
our fiscal house in order I I don't
think he would ever veto that bill I
would hope to think he wouldn't there's
talk of social security or Medicare
could be at risk is that true that
that's fear-mongering by Joe Biden and
the Democrats the Republicans are not
tying Social Security or Medicare to the
debt limit I as the chairman of the Ways
and Means Committee we have jurisdiction
over Social Security and Medicare I can
tell you right now we will not be tying
it to the debt limit we are not cutting
Social Security or Medicare this is just
Scare Tactics that this Administration
is just trying to do now I know the debt
limit is just one thing you have a lot
on your agenda you have a hearing that
you have set up to take your committee
on the road next week it is your field
hearing your first one on the state of
the American economy you're going to
West Virginia let me tell you this is I
made it a point that the very first
hearing that this committee will do will
be a field hearing because we want to go
to the places where Real Americans are I
want real Americans to to come before
the committee tell us their issues and
then give us their ideas and to solve
these problems it seems like in
Washington DC it's only the wealthy and
well-connected that get up here to Lobby
we need to make sure that Real Americans
have a voice and so we're going to have
filled hearings all over this country
West Virginia is Appalachia it's so
similar to my home which is the Ozarks
very very similar and we have a member
from our committee Miss Carol Miller
That's from West Virginia so I thought
it'd be a perfect location but we're
going to be traveling this entire
country to hear how small businesses
working class families and farmers are
being affected in today's economy and
also where they've been affected with
prior tax policy prior trade policy and
how they're affected when it comes to
Health Care affordability and access
it's how we figure out the issues and
figure out the solutions from Real
Americans not lobbyists and Washington
when you meet people are they surprised
I mean you look at your chairman of the
Ways and Means Committee in the house
people would think that you're some sort
of a a bureaucrat from Washington
you talked about being from the Ozarks I
mean you didn't come up for money not
even close right you know I I'm a
product of the working class my father
was an auto mechanic and a minister and
my mother worked at a factory just so we
had health insurance
um I live on the same family farm that I
purchased when my grandfather died when
I was in law school and guess what it
never had running water
um wow so I understand what that's like
but so many Americans have those
experiences and the Republican party is
the party of the working class and as
chairman of the house Ways and Means
Committee I want to make sure that those
priorities are reflective I want to make
sure that our priorities are the working
class Americans small businesses and
Farmers not the woke corporations that
have shed their American identity to
become beholden to China One issue I
know since you oversee taxation on your
committee and as chairman one issue that
people bring up is the child tax credit
what is going to happen with that people
got sort of advanced payments on that do
you want to bring that back back or is
there a movement to do that you know the
Republican party is the party that
started the child tax credit if you
recall back in 2017 when we did the the
tax cut and jobs act we doubled the
child tax credit from one thousand to
two thousand dollars and that expires in
2025. so I believe that we should be
able to find some common ground
um of course back during the American
Rescue plan the Democrats suspended the
work requirement on the child tax credit
which created a lot of problems in fact
if you look at the stats all of the Year
2021 only 1.6 million people returned to
the workforce after the work requirement
of the child tax credit was eliminated
but when that work requirement came back
in effect on the child tax credit at the
end of uh 2021 just in the first two
months of January and February alone 1.7
million people returned to the work so I
think we can find some common ground on
the child tax credit but there has to be
a work requirement and hopefully we can
deliver some kind of Middle Ground I
have to ask you there's a new
congressman from New York and he
represents my district Mike Lawler you I
don't know if you've met him yet he's
one of the new Republicans in the house
and he has a push where he wants to
revisit what Republicans did under
President Trump with the tax changes
were you limited salt the state and
local tax deduction
his beef is that it's ten thousand
dollars capped for single ten thousand
four couples he wants to double that to
twenty thousand is that reasonable
you know Mike Lawler is a great new
member of Congress he's actually my
next-door neighbor so you do know very
well okay yeah his office is right next
door to mine in Longworth so he has
already been bending my ear about this
and I can tell you he's a big advocate
for the folks in your District because I
know New York is a very high tax state
yeah you know I should show you my top
my property tax bill in my small house
you know this is a very dicey issue but
I don't believe the tax code should have
marriage penalties and that's an issue
that you have within that provision that
you just cited and that's what he's
trying to address and fix so I think
there's something that we can all look
at it but like I said it's a dicey issue
it's brave for Mike Lawler to be
bringing it up and he's definitely
working hard for the people that sent
him to Washington you know people
describe you and your role not just you
but the role you now have as chairman as
one of the most powerful men in all of
Congress how does that feel all I I
don't I don't know about all of that but
it's just it's pretty humbling to have
the opportunity when you're just a farm
kid from Southeast Missouri
um to be able to just serve in Congress
let alone to be chairman of the the best
Committee in Congress that has
jurisdiction overall tax and trade and
Social Security and I just I just want
to be able to help make a positive
impact for working class families and
and farmers and small businesses a lot
of times they're overlooked and they're
just considered flyover country by some
of the leadest and and that's not going
to happen with me as chairman how's ways
and means committee chairman Jason Smith
a republican congressman from Missouri
new to that role thank you very much for
joining us we appreciate it thank you
sir
[Music]
foreign
Hill recorded the first Blues hit and
changed music Mimi Smith was born in
1891 in Cincinnati Ohio across roads of
American musical influences in New York
City in the early 20th century Smith
became a Vaudeville performer singing
dancing and even performing comedy Mamie
Smith recorded the song Crazy Blues in
1920 she lay down the track with the
backing band her Jazz hounds at 25 West
45th Street in Manhattan on August 10
1920. crazy Blues was the first Blues
hit and became a huge success selling 75
000 copies in the first month alone it
generated up to a million dollars in
revenue for the label according to
various reports that was a phenomenal
figure for the era in the song Crazy
Blues Smith famously laments I can't eat
bite because the man I love he don't
treat me right Smith wrapped up the gift
of raw American Blues in a tiny bow of
polished pop professionalism she was the
first artist to share music of the miss
Mississippi Delta with a mainstream
audience her version of traditional
delta blues was ramped up into rock and
roll by American artists like Chuck
Berry in the 1950s Blues reached across
the Atlantic and expired a generation of
young British musicians too including
Keith Richards of The Rolling Stones
Mamie Smith enjoyed Fame and a career on
stage and in film after she recorded
crazy Blues she died in 1946 but her
voice and her work lives on in recorded
versions of her music
foreign
Fox News Radio On Demand on the Fox News
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite Fox News talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
Fox News Radio newscasts On Demand Fox
News Radio and the Fox News app download
it today Raiden review the Fox News
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your Fox News
commentary David Marcus
what's on your mind New York city mayor
Eric Adams has had it with the migrants
and who can blame them he and Gotham as
a whole have bent over backwards to
accommodate the flood of humanity
Unleashed by President Joe Biden's
bumbling border policies but some of
those migrants are now laughing in our
faces maybe just maybe it's time for him
to call for some of these malcontents to
be deported
this week we saw full out protests and
the erection of yet another bidenville
tent city outside midtown's Watson Hotel
went ungrateful migrants were set to be
moved to a facility at the Brooklyn
Cruise terminal mind you these are some
of the people who have been causing
Mayhem in these hotels as widely
reported throughout the media Adams is
now begging the federal government to
help him out as the Border crisis
crashes into the five boroughs he means
money of course but why not ask for real
help why not ask the federal government
to deport those single adult males who
refused to play by our rather generous
rules one has to ask are these genuine
Asylum Seekers who would do anything to
escape the punishing and unlawful
conditions of their Homeland or tourists
set to give mayor Adams a poor Yelp
review what exactly is going on here
since the Biden Administration has
decided that just about anybody can
claim Asylum for just about any reason
his honor is stuck providing room
service and Xboxes to groan single men
sadly that may constitute assimilation
in today's broken American society but
why won't Adams demand these people be
shown the door deportation is the one
solution to this problem that Democrats
like Adams cannot abide Oh They'll evict
migrants from Martha's Vineyard to an
army base faster than you can say Cesar
Chavez but send them out of the country
that's supposedly inhumane so where do
Adams and his Democrat allies think the
migrants should go some farm community
in Idaho the Appalachian Mountains of
West Virginia those locales didn't sign
up to be Sanctuary cities New York did
was that all just talk as comedian Jerry
Seinfeld once pointed out to a rental
car clerk anybody can just take
reservations the important part is
holding the reservation well now tens of
thousands of people in the country on
very questionable grounds are calling in
their reservations and Adams has no
answers there is an answer and it's
obvious it's the answer any of us would
say to an unruly guest in our own home
take what we are offering or leave if
mayor Adams is serious about this
problem if he's worried about the actual
consequences and not just his political
Ambitions that he should be calling for
Swift and decisive action the most
obvious answer and frankly the one most
likely demanded by our laws is to deport
those who refuse to accept our system
and instead insist we handle their
situation on their terms not hours the
American people even mostly liberal New
Yorkers are not going to stand for this
much longer we don't get free hotel
rooms we don't get to dictate what our
government provides for us half the time
we doubt we have any say at all if Adams
wants to lead he has a chance if he
wants to be a new voice in the Democrat
Party then he can be he can do it by
demanding to fight and Deport those
migrants who refuse to play by the rules
this shouldn't be particularly
controversial if these young single men
are truly escaping oppression then what
New York is offering is a godsend if not
then it's time to leave New York needs a
leader who can say this and make it
happen
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
listen to the all-new Brett Bear podcast
featuring Common Ground in-depth talks
with lawmakers from opposite sides of
the aisle along with all your bread bear
favorites like his All-Star panel and
much more available now at
foxnewspodcasts.com or wherever you get
your podcasts